James do you feel like independent
filmmakers are getting better as
business people or do they still have a
long way to go I think there's a very
individual to individual basis is the
answer to that I think that many
filmmakers have realized that there are
avenues to create that they can monetize
because we now do have so many platforms
I'll give you a great example I don't
know if you know who crystal chappell is
she's a soap opera actress and and when
the soap operas started to go off of
network television there were a lot of
people that started going out of jobs
because if you work in soaps that's kind
of what you do it's very hard to cross
out of that although there are plenty of
examples but in general most people that
work in soap operas will always work in
soap operas and so what she started
doing was creating her own web series
soap operas using all of the fans and
all the people that watch them
religiously every day on television at
twelve o'clock whatever it was to create
their own stories with their own
parameters without the network standards
without the broadcast standards and they
charge twenty thirty dollars a season
and if you get you know 5,000 10,000
people to sign up for that which they
did they can monetize that they can pay
everyone normal rates people can keep
living and working in doing and that's a
good example of how the internet and all
of these new platforms have created new
ways for people to take their projects
directly to the people that will buy
them as opposed to making something
that's mass-market you know it's not
like making the Avengers for everybody
in independent film especially with this
new era we now have the capacity to say
okay what is the number that makes sense
to make this project for and who is the
people who who is the people who are
people who are going to watch the film
and if you can identify that then
suddenly you can figure out ways to
monetize your projects so i think that
people like crystal chappell and they're
plenty of other examples are doing
just that they're finding their audience
because they know who their audience is
and then they're going straight to them
and cutting out the middleman and that's
how you do it
you